so today I want to talk to you about
help help in making right decisions help
with life transitions and in particular
help in making the most out of school
and I want to focus most of my talk on
the transition between secondary and
post-secondary education so about one in
four of high school students today in
Canada when I'll go on to do any
post-secondary education and fewer still
will go on if they're from rural areas
or disadvantaged family backgrounds so
think about why that happens one
possibility is that students know what
they're doing and they're making the
right decisions that's the conclusion by
treating education as it as a
well-thought-out investment students
don't go on it's because they think
correctly the costs are going to exceed
the lifetime benefits and some recent
media reports have encouraged that
conclusion pointing out this actually
quite difficult to show evidence of
skill improvement in terms of recent
university entrance and all the while
many students scrape by with bare
minimum grades or don't complete it all
and well that's true and it's it's a
concern I want to assert you today that
the convincing evidence still
overwhelmingly supports the idea that
faced with the decision to stop at high
school and start your lifetime career or
go on to college or university there's
at least some program out there which is
likely to make you much better off and
that's not just in terms of income but
lots of other outcomes as well like
better job satisfaction more job
security better health better family
outcomes more social participation and
so it returns to post-secondary so high
why then don't students take more
advantage of these opportunities
certainly financial barriers may be
playing a role here even with access to
government grants and loans but I want
to suggest you today that there may be
other things going on that we should
think about so recent evidence in
psychology and sociology has
demonstrated that seemingly small
differences in the way that changes
choices or opportunities are presented
can lead to big differences in behavior
when you're structuring a routine when
routines need to be changed in order to
alter behavior individuals often succumb
to their own inertia they stick with the
routine even when it seems likely that
the expected Venice from changing might
be big and that's especially true when
it comes to making decisions with
immediate costs and distant long-term
benefits exactly the case that it is
with higher education and who's making
the decisions in the higher education
teenagers right anyone with the teenager
or just experience in being a teenager
can relate that Alison's are
particularly predisposed to just not
really thinking it through or or not
thinking about these long-term
consequences and that's not to say that
teenagers make mistakes all the time or
that the only reason for low levels of
education attainment is because that of
inertia or or or not not sticking to a
routine but at least sometimes these
types of influences get in the way of
some individuals realizing better
long-term outcomes so how can we help
I want to give you an example of what
might be going on how we can help
structure routines to better improve and
make children succeed more in school we
actually already do some of this we just
maybe don't realize it for example a
six-year-old doesn't actually choose to
go to school right she's not thinking
about all the great expected benefits
that she's going to get when she grows
up if she can just get on that orange
bus my parents registering their child
to go to school and walking them to the
door and government setting a minimum
school leaving age so that all children
start by the age of six or examples that
how we help we also make it easy to
transition between grades when a student
finishes grade seven they're
automatically registered for grade and
when she finishes grade eight a system
is set up to make it easy to get to the
right high school with minimum fuss but
the same cannot be said for the
transition between secondary and
post-secondary education right
historically most individuals finish
their education at the end of high
school and college and university was
intended for a relative few but since
then the demand for those with
post-secondary credentials has massively
increased but the process to get there
has remained basically as always been
students still have to figure out where
they want to go they have to find the
application we have to pay a fee and
then they have to figure out how they're
going to afford to go and so if the
process to go to keep going we're going
to have to do we're going to think more
about it so I suggest you in short the
reason why some individuals not all but
some don't go on
to post sancta secondary there's two
reasons one the process not simple and
is not salient and two there's not
enough help to deal with the process and
so if we can't simplify things more
we're going to have to perhaps offer
some help so here's an example this is
the FAFSA the Free Application for
Federal Student Aid every individual in
the US they want to qualify for
financial aid to go to college or just
learn about their eligibility they have
to fill out this form the paper form of
the FAFSA is 10 pages with more than a
hundred questions very personalized
information and specific information
things like exact earnings exact income
Social Security numbers and a signature
at the end to say that all of this is
correct if not maybe I might have to go
to jail or face a fine of twenty
thousand dollars and so if the process
of the FAFSA can't be simplified further
or if individuals are just not accessing
the form maybe a helping hand could help
what I have in mind is something that I
call personal assistants personal
assistants is one on one help from
someone experienced ideally someone you
trust and who genuinely cares about your
well-being it's a kind of hand-holding
at an opportune time it's someone coming
up to saying look I know you're probably
already interested in this but just
haven't don't know where to get started
don't know how to go about it or haven't
figured out how to change your routine
or get around round to it I have
experience with this I want to help you
and why don't we just sit down get it
right done right now there's lots of
opportunities for personal assistance to
a friend or a son or daughter
from a policy perspective is a little
bit more tricky because you have to come
up with situations with this
face-to-face contact with trusted agents
on a large scale so the idea my
colleagues in high had to help with the
FAFSA is to partner with a tax
preparation company in the US the taxes
are completed around the same time that
the FAFSA has to be completed and a lot
of the information on the FAFSA is the
same information contained on the tax
form and so if you could pre populate
the FAFSA with the information from the
tax form there'd only be a few remaining
questions that you would have to walk
through so we teamed up with art H&R
block which is you may know is a large
tax preparation company that fills out
forms mostly for low-income families the
company actually filled out more than 20
million forms last year and in our
experiment a parent would come in to get
their taxes done at H&R Block who has a
child in grade 12 transitioning out of
high school and they were asked at
random by the same person who just spent
an hour with them on their taxes whether
they wanted to stick around for an extra
10 minutes to get the FAFSA done for the
son or daughter so how can this help
there's actually a lot of ways that
personal assistance might be working one
is that it gets the thing that you're
trying to get them to do it makes it
more visible more salient just bringing
up the FAFSA might be enough to remind
the individual that they were intending
to do this or that this is something
they want to do personal assistance is
also it reduces complexity it removes
the need to go through the instructions
or go through the think about the forms
or worry about making mistakes when
you're filling out the form in fact in
our study the participants deavon didn't
even have to look at the form they just
had to respond to questions being asked
by the tax professional
and personal assistance can be
convenient if it's offered at an
opportune time it's a lot easier to sit
down with someone when you're already at
their office then to ask them to work
through on their own find time to carve
out change the routine and get it done
on their own and it can be reassuring
you have someone who is trying to help
you and is encouraging to get this form
done you're more likely to think that
it's a good idea and finally involves
social interaction you're working with
someone if you have any questions or
concerns you can get immediate feedback
it's a lot easier to change your routine
when someone's right there holding your
hand through it then leaving it up to
someone on their own to watch a video on
the internet or to read something so
let's see what happened in the
comparison group that didn't receive any
help in completing the FAFSA the filing
rates for about forty percent remember
these students were transitioning out of
high school so it's not surprising that
there were at least some filing but in
the in the personal assistance group the
filing rates went up to fifty six
percent a 16 percentage point difference
so that's a big change it didn't go up
to a hundred percent because the
students still have to sign the FAFSA
and they're not in the office so the
best we can do was complete the form and
then we sent it home first for the
parent to get the student to sign and
then put in a prepaid envelope and send
it back still things get interesting now
when looking later to see who's in
college a year later and the comparison
group thirty percent are in college in
the personal assistance group it goes up
to forty percent a ten percentage point
increase so think about that for a
moment we made the difference between
not going and going to college for one
in every ten people in our sample at
one-third increase that's big and not
only did did we get them to go but we
got them to stay the results for going
for two consecutive
years are about the same and as striking
as these results are we think we can do
better there was that issue with the
signature and also we only help with the
financial aid form we didn't do anything
about the second form that needs
completing which is the program
application and we were only able to
help families i went to H&R Block so why
not go directly to the high schools
especially the ones that are low
transition the ones were safe fewer than
half of them are going on and that's the
motivation behind the life after high
school project which is going on right
now here in Ontario across low
transition high schools throughout the
province and is sponsored by the
Ministry of training colleges in India
and universities and the idea is the
same we try to simplify the process and
follow up with personal assistance in
class so that every grade 12 student
leaving a high school does so with an
offer of acceptance with the program
that they help choose and a financial
aid package so that the bridge from high
school to post-secondary starts to look
like the bridge from Grade seven to
eight it's still the students choice on
whether they want to cross that bridge
but at least the option value becomes
more real so this is going on now there
the workshops are being done in class
and the applications are being paid for
by us and we'll see what happens maybe
in a year from now I'll be giving them
to talk about that so I want to conclude
by noting that having to fill out a form
is an easy example of where personalized
assistance and simplification can help
and college applications are just one
example we can also think of things like
helping students take the right courses
so they stay on an academic track or
that they graduate on time we're helping
parents with the form for the registered
education savings
but you can also think about personal
assistants more than just helping with
forums but as a general way to encourage
better behavior you can think of it as a
way for example of setting up a routine
and making easier to take tutorials to
attend tutorials in life there are lots
of situations not just in education
where we tend to follow routine and we
tend to take the path of least
resistance and when you have that
perspective you realize that there's a
lot of opportunity for personal
assistance not just an education and so
I hope you'll think about these and
maybe come up with your own ways to help
others and help yourselves thanks
you